to his supporters he's a hero and
they're happy to celebrate him they come
in droves every day to the town of omoi
Kea to visit the house of Nnamdi Kanu
the leader of a Probie Afra organization
[Applause]
the zoo is Canas word for Nigeria he
spent years in London where he used a
radio station to call for the division
of Nigeria when he finally returned to
his homeland he was arrested he spent
nearly two years in detention because of
his divisive speeches he was accused of
treason felony but he was never formally
charged and was later released the whole
affair only served to raise Kanu's
profile securing him yet more followers
under the conditions of his parole he's
not allowed to address his supporters
interviews are also banned but Kanu
speaks at every opportunity expounding
his radical racist ideology Nigeria is
not a civilized country people will
behave like animals they are not
reasonable enough they're not
disciplined enough they are not mentally
developed enough to run a transparent
civil society for them they have a
feudal mindset where you have the ruling
class and you know a multitude of
poverty-stricken people who never utters
any word in rebellion or to even ask
questions about their plight there is
one thing we are determined to challenge
don't you think you insult a lot of
Nigerians with that I'm being very kind
to be honest I could have used far more
harsher words to describe them just a
few kilometers from Connie's house a
museum tells of a dark chapter in the
history of this region the Biafra war
which began fifty years ago was an
unequal battle right from the start
those fighting for independence mainly
from the EBU people had self-made
weapons and tanks they faced the entire
rest of the country with far more
sophisticated weaponry and powerful
international backing Biafra maintained
its resistance for two years over two
million people died during that time
many of them simply starved to death
since then there has been little attempt
to process those traumatic events most
schools don't even teach on the Nigerian
civil war since the end of the war many
Evo's have felt neglected and excluded
by the Nigerian state they've been
asking for reforms in order to have a
stronger voice in governments but hardly
anything has changed this is why a lot
of youth in particular are increasingly
listening to radical voices but there's
also moderate voices warning of an
escalation
oh yeah Bo chiku is an attorney he's
calling for serious political dialogue
on reforms to ensure radical voices like
that of nanda khan who lose their appeal
I was a little boy during the Nigerian
civil war and I tested and the
experience part of the war the violence
the Honda the deprivation
those of our age and those before us
tend to employ moderation when
discussing the book question which is
the Nigerian question in this country
but those are talents who were mostly
born after the Nigerian civil war do not
rationalize the former capital of is now
home to thousands of other Nigerians
from the north of the country Alhaji
Omar Sadiki has lived here for 35 years
he's an ethnic house' but his children
were born here and they feel more at
home here than in the north he's helping
his family will be able to continue
living here in peace so I'm the two
brothers the houses and the e boys let
us come together let them forget the
past
let us from a new generation for where
our children to be staying and enjoying
ourself crisis will not give us anything
nante Kanu remains undaunted he's
demanding a referendum on independence
for Biafra Connor says if there is no
referendum by November he and his
supporters will boycott all future
elections in the region